صور لاول مره نرى الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد يتطا قدماه ارض المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بعد 12 عاما من الغياب حيث اننا
نتابع معكم هذه الصور الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد وصل اذا المطار وطبعا كانت اعلنت
الرئاسه السوريه بانه سيتجه فعلا الى جده
للمشاركه في القمه العربيه الان في مقدمه
استقباله نتابع معكم احمد ابو الغيط وايضا
عدد كبير من المسؤولين في مقدمه استقبال
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد نتابع معكم هذه
الصور طبعا كانت الجامعه العربيه جمدت
عضويه سوريا في الجامعه العربيه في 2011
على خلفيه اندلاع الازمه السوريه هناك
ترحيب عربي كبير بعوده سوريا الى الحضن
العربي هذه المره حيث هناك ايضا ترحيب على
صعيد رسمي سياسي على صعيد ايضا شعبي
لمشاركه سوريا مره اخرى بعد غياب اثني عشر
عاما في قمه عربيه تجمع كل العرب احمد ابو
الغيط امين عام الجامعه العربيه كان قال
بان هذه المره الحضور العربي مكتمل الحضور
العربي كامل من حيث مستوى تمثيل القاده
والرؤساء والحكام الذين قدموا ووصلوا الى
ارض المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتحديدا جدا
حيث ستقام القمه العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثين هذا هو الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد اذا يصل ونتابع معكم هذه الصور التي
نشاهدها اذا الان طبعا كان هناك
تصريحات استبقت اذا سبقت وصول وصول الرئيس
السوري طبعا نائب امير منطقه مكه
الامير بدر بن سلطان في ايضا مقدمه
مستقبلي الوفد السوري نتابع معكم ايضا
وزير الخارجيه فيصل المقداد وطبعا الامير
بدر بن سلطان نتابع معكم هذه الصور الان
هذه طبعا محادثات تجمع بين الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد وايضا احمد ابو الغيط امين عام
الجامعه العربيه وطبعا هذه القمه التي
تعقد في ظروف استثنائيه تمر بها العالم
وخصوصا ايضا المنطقه العربيه في ظل
التطورات الايجابيه التي طرات في المنطقه
العربيه حيث قال ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان نحن الان في مرحله تصفير
الازمات في المنطقه طبعا سبقت هذه القمه
التي من المقرر عقدها يوم غد وكل الانظار
تتجه نحو المملكه العربيه السعوديه والى
جده بالتحديد بعد المؤشرات الايجابيه التي
طرات مؤخرا منها عوده سوريا الى الحضن
العربي وبالتالي هناك المضي قدما في تحقيق
النحو ملفات عده في المنطقه واهمها ايضا
ابرزها الازمه السوريه التي طال عمرها
وطال امدها اكثر من عشر سماوات واثني عشر
عاما حتى اليوم لكي نرى الرئيس السوري
طبعا هذه مشاهد لافته اليوم مشاهد تستوجب
النظر وتستوجب ايضا التدقيق خصوصا بان
الرئيس بشار الاسد اليوم في جده في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بعد غياب منقطع
النظير بعد غياب عن الجامعه العربيه بعد
غياب عن الحضن العربي اثر اندلاع الازمه
والحرب السوريه التي طال امدها حتى الان
يعني هناك تعويل بان الامور ستالوها خطوات
جديده يعني كان هناك حديث بعد ان تم اقرار
اعاده اعاده عضويه سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه بانه سيكون هناك خطوه مقابل خطوه
وبالتالي الامور تاتي تباعا وتدريجيا ولن
تكون يعني مره واحده الازمه في سوريا هي
ما زالت مستمره حتى اليوم ولن تحل بين
ليله ولد وضحاها اقله
كااعاده ترتيب للملفات اقل اصبح الحوار
اليوم ممكنا هناك رؤى وخطط ولكن هذه الخطط
خطوه تليها خطوه نتابع معكم اذا ما زلنا
هناك محادثات تجري الان في هذه المشاهد
طبعا التي وصلتنا قبل قليل لوصول الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد ويتحدث ايضا الى الامير
بدر بن سلطان تبع معكم اذا هذه الصور منا
وسط جده وتحديدا من مقر انعقاد القمه
العربيه الثانيه والثلاثين ويشارك فيها
الاسد اذا للمره الاولى بعد 12 عاما بعد
تجميد عضويه بلاده في الجامعه العربيه في
2011 على خلفيه اندلاع الازمه السوريه هذه
هي اذا المشاهد التي ننقلها لكم طبعا هذا
هو الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد وطبعا هناك
تعويل كبير في هذه القمه في يتعلق بعدد
كبير من الملفات من بينها الازمه في سوريا
وايضا
مساله السودان وهذه الازمه الشائكه التي
طالت ايضا بعد اكثر من شهر مندلاع الازمه
بين الطرفين العسكريين المتحاربين فلسطين
ايضا على راس جدول الاعمال واليمن طبعا
هذه هي اذا السياره التي تنقل الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد طبعا هذه صور متعدده
عباره عن صور مختلفه للحظه وصول الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد وايضا خلال القاعه قاعه
المؤتمرات وايضا لمغادرته في السياره
وطبعا هذا هي الصور التي نشاهدها لحظه
وصوله طبعا في المطار وكان في مقدمه
مستقبليه الامير بدر بن سلطان